le montana l'hôtel le plus luxueux de
port-au-prince dans le plus riche des
quartiers pétion ville
quand le bâtiment s'est effondré il y a
dix ans il est devenu le symbole d'une
catastrophe qui a frappé sans
discrimination pauvre irish comme on a
un cochon vous verser par l'effondrement
de ce bâtiment privé compenser secure
une soixantaine de personnes ont perdu
la vie dans les décombres du montana
après avoir passé dix jours et des nuits
à secourir les blessés à consoler les
familles les propriétaires en plongés
dans une difficile reconstruction
ils ont tous et entamer les travaux de
reconstruction n'ont pas été découragés
ils ont persévéré
c'est un bon exemple pourquoi c'est un
bon exemple d'avoir cru en la
reconstruction de ce pays
faut y croire quand on regarde le
principal hôpital public de port au
prince à moitié détruit lors du séisme
on se demande si le gouvernement haïtien
ya cru en la reconstruction
c'était une priorité mais le nouvel
hôpital restent inachevées faute de
fonds c'est pourtant le projet financé
par les etats-unis et la france
car des problèmes mais je sais aussi
qu'à des négociations qui se poursuit
avec les partenaires pour pouvoir
réaliser vraiment ce retard qu'on attend
désespérément qu'on attend avec
impatience la médecin diriger la
pédiatrie à l'époque du séisme elle a
soigné ses petits patients sous la tente
pendant deux ans aujourd'hui l'hôpital à
moitié réparer n'a que 400 lits au lieu
de 700 lorsque yam d'avoir davantage de
patients qui arrivent aux urgences on
est vite dépassé beaucoup d'églises
lourdement endommagé tardent ou six à
être reconstruites et l'église
catholique d'haïti ne donne pas de
raison claire le vatican aurait été
généreux mais les paroisses manque de
moyens c'est un nouveau tremblement de
terre la catastrophe sera aussi
important selon une étude menée par une
association d'architecte
90% des reconstructions été fait sans
permis et ne respectent pas les normes
parasismiques
on a de quoi s'inquiéter et a demandé
qu'il ya véritablement changement
changement de paradigme changement
d'état le problème c'est une absence de
l'état cette absence est
particulièrement visible au coeur de la
ville où le trou laissé par le palais
présidentiel demeure béant ici ce filon
de loi radio canada à port-au-prince